- [Instructor] Talk about in other videos,
the Middle Ages refers to
that roughly 1,000 year period
of time in Europe from the end
of the Western Roman empire
in 476 until we get to
about 1,000 years later
with the emergence of the Renaissance
and the Age of Exploration.
And we associate it with
knights in shining armor
and their code of chivalry,
with kings and castles
surrounded by moats.
And we also associate it
with the feudal system,
which is how most of Europe was governed
during the Middle Ages.
Now many of you are
probably familiar with some
of the key actors within
the feudal system.
At the top, you would have a king.
Now, the king would rule over a kingdom.
Now this is not so easy to govern,
especially during the Middle Ages,
and the king might owe many people things,
especially people who helped
the king come to power,
helped him depose the previous
king or to conquer this land.
And so, in exchange for
that, and to help govern,
he might grant land or
fiefs to other people.
And the key currency in the Middle Ages
under the feudal system is land
and land in exchange
for loyalty and service.
So, this whole thing is a kingdom.
Now, right over here, this is a duchy
and a duchy will be controlled by a duke.
I guess they didn't call it ducky
because that just
doesn't sound as serious.
So, the king might grant a duchy,
a duchy, to a duke,
and in exchange, the duke
would provide loyalty,
pledge their fealty.
If the kingdom is threatened,
the duke will fight
alongside the king, would
provide their own troops.
If the king wants to go
conquer other territories,
same thing, and also
provide the king with taxes,
which might be in the form of coinage,
depending on what time and
region we are in the Middle Ages
or it might be in the form of a percentage
of the agricultural
production from this duchy.
Now the terminology here is that the duke
would be one of the king's vassals
or would be vassal to the king.
Now a duchy tends to be a fairly
large amount of territory.
In medieval England, a duke was
the highest title of nobility.
There was variations on duke.
Now the duke might have his own manor
or might even have multiple
manors that he rules
directly over that has his own serfs
or free peasants working
that land, providing output,
which helps generate
some of the tax revenue
that goes to the king or provides some
of the necessities for
the duke's own household.
But the rest of the duchy,
they might subdivide further
and they would be lord
over their own vassals.
So, for example, this piece
of land right over here,
this duke might provide
it to someone else,
let's say a count, in which
case this would be called
a county, and that is where we
get our modern term, county.
And this count would be vassal to the duke
and the duke would be
the lord of the count.
And then the count can then be the lord
of someone else, of their vassals.
And this goes on and on and on,
all the way until you get
down to the level of the serfs
and the peasants, who are
actually doing the work.
But the main idea here is
that in exchange for land,
the king gave his duke a duchy,
or maybe the king's father
gave this duke's father this duchy,
and so this grant of land,
this is called a fief,
a critical term in the feudal system.
This county here, this is a fief.
In exchange for that,
the vassal gives the lord
resources, taxes, and loyalty.
Now the way I drew it here,
it seems quite organized
and clean, but the reality
of it, it isn't that clean.
Sometimes, a kingdom might directly,
some parts of it might be
subdivided into duchies,
some of it might be divided into a county
that is independent of any duchy.
You might have another
duchy right over here
that is not subdivided into counties.
You might have one count
that is more powerful
than another count, or one
count that might even be
more powerful than a duke someplace else.
So it can actually be quite chaotic
and hard to keep track of.
And this isn't all of the players.
I mentioned some of
the titles of nobility,
like duke and count,
and then below count
you might have a baron.
In England, the equivalent
of count was an earl,
who still presided over a county
and their wife was a countess.
And when I say preside,
they had almost full control over it.
They would even give
justice over the people
who happen to be within their fiefdom.
Now, I started this
video showing a picture
of a knight on horseback
and knights are probably
one of the strongest
association with medieval times,
so many of you are probably thinking,
where do knights fit into this?
The knight refers to
slightly different things,
depending on what region you are in
or what time period
within the Middle Ages,
but it generally refers
to a mounted soldier,
someone skilled in fighting,
someone who might have knight's armor.
But over time, it became
a prestigious title
that was given by a monarch or by a lord
in exchange for service,
oftentimes military service.
You might have a knight
who is granted a fief from,
say, this count right over here,
and say, they might be
lord of their own manor.
They might have their own
serfs who are not quite slaves,
but they're bonded
laborers who cannot leave
and don't have a lot of
rights, working the field.
You might have other
knights who got the title
but did not get the land.
And to complicate things further,
any of these characters
can have multiple titles.
For example, this duke
might also be knighted.
Now, it's worth noting that
these titles of nobility,
duke, count, baron, earl,
these tended to be hereditary.
You would pass it down from
one generation to the next,
as long as the next generation
pledged fealty to their lord.
The title knight, however,
was given for service
and did not tend to be passed down
from generation to generation.
And to be clear, these still
aren't all the actors here.
You also have the church,
which during medieval times,
was a very powerful institution.
At the top of the church,
you had the bishop of Rome,
also known as the pope,
and you had their bishops
in significant regions.
You also had monastic orders,
where you might have an abbot,
who is the head of a monastery,
where you have monks,
who, as part of that
monastery, are praying.
They might be farming, they
might be copying texts.
And there's also power
dynamics between these.
And as we're about to
see, you can even have
these non-religious figures pledging
fealty to religious figures.
So just to get a sense of what
these pledges of fealty were like.
You have a vassal.
In this homage ceremony, homage,
or sometimes said homage,
it really comes from
the French word, homme,
which refers to man.
So he is pledging to be his lord's man.
So this would be the lord right over here.
And this is an actual pledge
given by Bernard Atton,
Viscount of Carcassonne,
in the year 1110 in France.
"In the name of the
Lord, I, Bernard Atton,"
and I apologize for my pronunciation,
"Viscount of Carcassonne,
in the presence of my sons,"
and he goes on to list his sons.
"Nobles, and of many other honorable men,
"who have come to the monastery
of St. Mary of Grasse,"
or Grasse, "since lord Leo ,
abbot of the said monastery,
"has asked me, in the presence
of all those above mentioned,
"to acknowledge to him the
fealty and homage" or homage
"for the castles, manors,
and places which the patrons,
"my ancestors, held from
him and his predecessors
"and from the said monastery as a fief,
"and which I ought to hold as they held,
"I have made to the lord abbot Leo
"acknowledgement and
homage as I ought to do."
So, in this case, the lord is an abbot,
is a religious figure, is
the head of a monastery
and the vassal is a viscount.
You can kinda view them as vice count.
And notice, he's pledging
fealty to the abbot.
And in this case, it looks
like Bernard Atton's ancestors
were already vassals to the abbot
and so this is really renewing
it and so that the viscount
could essentially keep his fief.
Now to appreciate how
complicated this could get,
here on the timeline you see
when Henry the Second lived,
and as you can see, he had many titles.
He was eventually King of England.
You can see southern England up here.
He was Duke of Normandy,
Duke of Aquitaine,
which was interesting.
He got that as a dowery
when he marries Eleanor,
whose previous husband was King
Louis the Seventh of France.
He is Count of Maine, Anjou, Touraine.
And this is really interesting.
He's a king of one kingdom,
the Kingdom of England,
but he is also a duke and a
count within another kingdom,
the kingdom of France.
But this gives you a
sense of, to some degree,
how chaotic the Middle Ages were.
It wasn't well organized
like under the Roman empire
or under ancient Persia or
even most nation states today.
It was many different kingdoms organized
into many different duchies and counties.
There wasn't a very clear rhyme and reason
and positions and power
constantly shifted,
depending on loyalty, wars,
marriages, and inheritance.